this country a near collision at New
York's Kennedy airport is now under
investigation officials say an American
Airlines plane crossed a Runway where a
Delta flight was accelerating to take
off on Friday night Chris Van Cleef has
more on the close call that was
recognized just in the nick of time
Nelson 1943 canceled takeoff plans air
traffic controllers at New York's JFK
Airport spot a near disaster in the
making Friday night moments after
clearing a Delta 737 Bound for the
Dominican Republic with 151 people on
board for takeoff an American triple
seven heading to London with 137
passengers and 14 crew taxied across the
same Runway just as the Delta flight
barreled towards it picking up speed
those Pilots slammed on the brakes
safely stopping their takeoff about a
thousand feet from the other plane
according to the FAA all right then
anytime you have a Runway incursion like
this there's a potential for
very bad things to happen Robert sumwalt
is the former chair of the NTSB what are
they hoping to piece together here the
NTSB is going to be wanting to
understand what happened why did this
happen uh was there a distraction in the
in the cockpit of the American flight
was there a misunderstanding as to the
aircraft controlled clearance American
Airlines declined to comment on the
incident Delta says safety is its number
one priority and it will work with
investigators the NTSB will be looking
at the events leading up to what
essentially amounts to a wrong turn by
the American Airlines plane the last
class we were given we were cleared to
uh cross is that correct yes we'll
listen to the tapes but uh you were
supposed to depart Runway four left
you're currently holding short of uh
three One Less close calls like this are
rare but have happened before in 2017 an
Air Canada flight attempted to land on a
taxiway at San Francisco's airport
directly over us coming within about 13
feet of colliding with one of four
airliners waiting to take off no one was
hurt now the NTSB will focus on finding
out what went wrong Friday night for CBS
mornings I'm Chris Van Cleave